[Applause]
they haven't eaten anything for days
this is a protest against the end of
Dhaka all of them arrived as small
children in the US this is Monica
Camacho she crossed the Mexican border
with her mother when she was seven years
old she was the first one in her family
to learn English all of them finished
high school and our University now as
they protested outside the capital
politicians like Representative Nancy
Pelosi or Senator Cory Booker encouraged
them the dreamers goal is to find a
long-term solution for them and for
their parents who are also undocumented
only those who entered the country when
they were younger than 16 and after 2007
are eligible for the daca program
Monica's dad was the first one to come
to the United States with a people
smuggler
two years later mother and daughter
followed the same dangerous path through
the desert from Mexico to Arizona I was
mad
but now that I'm older I understand why
he did it and and if I was in his shoes
I've done the same thing for my family
Monica said her battle is much smaller
than the one her parents had to fight my
dreamers are my parents my dad because
he you know he wanted to give us a
better life
he wanted us to have better
opportunities than what he had when he
was younger he only went to school for
six months all we want to do is you know
make this this country better you know
this is our home
those fasting came here from across the
US and stayed in this Washington church
Monica's parents also paid a visit to
support their daughter she didn't decide
to come we brought her like all these
kids here they wanted to see her mother
or her father but they didn't know what
they were doing I came because of
poverty I worked in Mexico from 6 a.m.
to 6 p.m. for 100 pesos I wasn't able to
afford anything I wanted my kids to
study and have a good profession use ish
ins also turned out to spur on the
dreamers in their week-long fast they
played a kind of music called cumbia the
Latin rhythm is known for its different
influences from diverse cultures
diversity a mixture that also
characterizes the dreamers
[Music]